when you started in stand-up comedy like
what what years were those like 80s
early 80s uh 82 three four were you like
15 or something i was like i think i was
like 17 when i first started and then
how do you start let's go let's go over
this because i like this whole this
whole trajectory you decide you want to
do stand-up comedy right yeah i saw
steve martin perform first of all my dad
had comedy albums right you know what
your dad has is what you're interested
in and there was san francisco in the
early 60s had like a comedy scene and my
dad when he was dating my mother that's
where they would go out he'd go to the
hungry eye did you grow up in san
francisco yeah just again i was born in
san francisco and they hate ashbury
before the hit ashby was a hit ash
buried so you decide you want to be a
stand-up comedian and you go to like a a
place i didn't know i heard that there
was a club and then i that there was a
place in town and the big guy there was
robin williams right yeah well there was
a scene because of him basically clubs
opened because he was there it was the
weirdest thing robin was such a like a
supernova that like you know he was in
orbit that we all kind of rotated around
and robin williams wasn't in the la
scene he was in the san francisco
comedies he could have stayed in l.a was
way the clubs were better the girls were
better looking everything right he came
up and thank god for him because you
know he would literally
he mentioned in playboy magazine he did
the big interview when he made it or her
and i don't think people today realize
how huge robin williams was when robin
would show up the audience would come
hoping that he would there be there and
more times not he would show up right
and then the place would get packed and
then he'd do two hours and then they'd
all leave was the whole two hours good
or was it like maybe 10 of it good it
was a very high percentage the thing
about him was he was electric so he
would go off what was happening and if
it wasn't going good he'd switch quickly
right and he would like make everything
um
seem improvisational and some of it was
so was he your teacher in a way like
like you were a young kid starting out
didn't you work at some comedy club
that's the worst thing i was i was the
bartender you were the bartender but it
was easy because only had beer but you
didn't have uh uh uh a big act no way i
had no i didn't know what to do first of
all i saw it but when you see robin
williams would you get intimidated
but that was the thing about it so okay
you know i can't do that so it's okay
i'll just do i
okay that's unreachable right but he had
this thing which is a blessing and a
curse which is like he's the comic
genius and so he had to live up to that
every time right but but but he kind of
you know he fulfilled it more times than
not and sometimes you know he'd get on
stage and then other people would go up
with him and he was like he just had
another level of energy did he have bad
nights like was there nights that he
bombed and people were like [ __ ] you no
was it it was always gone because the
audience was so psyched to see him that
he would really have to work to under
deliver if that makes sense so he was
already on mark and mindy he's already
winning oh yeah he was already way up
there and you knew him as a personal
friend because you were the bartender
there and then you got to hang out i was
one of those guys like everybody bugged
him comedians would come by hey i'm
broke man and then he'd give him he'd
take money out of his own pocket wow so
and here's here's rob williams to me
which sums him up to me like he would
always say nice things to her you did
good on letterman
and then uh letterman likes you oh you
can tell
and it just whatever to make you feel
good he came up and saw me perform and i
had this you know when you come up you
have your killer bits and i had an end
to my netflix special i was gonna do
this big ending where this you know it's
a woman of having sex you know and then
she said women are still thinking about
stuff even when you're having sex with
them so she's bent over she's coming up
and she's thinking of all this stuff and
i thought that was the ending and i had
it and it was perfect and then robin
came up with a better ending he said to
you i've got a better ending for you
myself oh you got to say like uh credit
cards jewelry distract them
right here jewelry jewelry and i'm like
what that's better how generous of him
yeah well he was just a
were you a close friend of his no i mean
i never wanted to like i didn't want
anything from him because everyone was
bugging him and i like i'm one of those
guys who just um
uh you know i was in his orbit and i was
happy to be around him
you